being well prepared is a necessity
during a time like this
and that includes making sure your
vehicle is ready to take on
whatever adventure is next subaru of las
vegas has you covered
[Applause]
so when you buy a new subaru you have
the original factory
warranty that's a three-year 36 plan and
your
powertrain is usually covered for five
years and 60 000 miles
a lot of people don't consider though
that after those warranties expire
how are they going to have those
components covered and not just the
engine
and the transmission and the all-wheel
drive but also like for instance air
conditioning high-tech features
you know just the center stack alone
where your radio is
that's two thousand dollars if you have
to replace it because it also includes a
lot of components for the
air conditioning in the heating system
or the headlights
headlight unit is a thousand dollars to
replace a lot of people don't realize
the high-tech nature of all these
components
make them very expensive and that's why
the subaru added security plan
is so worthwhile i like to go right to
the gold plus plan because the gold plus
is going to cover all of your major
components and
it is most like the original
factory warranty in the fact that it
covers all of your
high-tech electronics it covers
mechanical
it'll cover um just i mean it literally
is
almost a bumper to bumper extended
service plan
you know there are a few exceptions but
it
is an amazing plan and you can get it in
different lengths in other words you can
get a five year sixty thousand mile plan
you can get
a seven one hundred you can get an eight
ten year plan
all the plans include towing allowance
rental allowance
and the gold plus plan even includes
trip interruption
which if you're out somewhere out away
from home
and you have to have your vehicle worked
on they will help pay
for your incidentals your room and board
during the time that you are without
your vehicle
also subaru has some excellent
maintenance plans that are in addition
to the
added security plan and the maintenance
will cover your oil changes it'll cover
tire rotations it'll cover the the
routine maintenance items and
those also are available in two and
three and four year plans
so we have a another product called the
subaru
equity shield and the equity shield is a
great plan
to put on your vehicle when you purchase
it and those aren't new or
used vehicles and it will cover
basically
tire dent ding
it'll it'll cover some of the things if
you lose your keys
it covers the replacement and the
reprogramming of a brand new set of keys
and so that is the equity shield plan
and it is a great thing to have
and typical subaru ownership is a long
time
people drive their subarus and they
typically will hand them down to family
members
because they are such a long lasting
product and
so that's why these extra coverages are
a great
purchase check out subaru of las vegas
on roy horn way
call 702-495-2100 or visit
subaru of las vegas.com and they have a
special for you
the february true love event offers zero
percent apr financing
on select 2021 models for well-qualified
buyers
las vegas now will